it's about three weeks worth of hair
growth uh i wasn't too bad the hair came
up so well because i waited so long so
that was a plus this is sierra
she's a licensed esthetician
and she's got some crazy
stories has anyone ever
started during a session um that is a
great question and
yeah i've been farted on before in a
session
not my favorite wait until you hear
about this i have had an alarming amount
of women come in for brazilian with
literal poop in their ass but the
absolute worst the worst client was a
regular couldn't even see where to wax i
had to wax around it and the smell when
asked by the internet why sierra would
service those particular clients
her response was clear
first of all i didn't have a choice i
was working at european wax center and
we were work like dogs if we denied a
client then we just wouldn't have a job
like that's it
but i don't take clients now none of my
recent clients have ever been so
disrespectful to not take a shower and
for the people blaming me for not saying
anything i had little to no interaction
with the client before they came in that
was the front desk and i also should not
have to tell a grown ass woman to shower
before her appointment honestly it's
disrespectful and rude as a client to
not respect your waxer enough to be
clean before you get waxed so before you
blame me have respect for the person
that's doing a service for you just when
you thought things couldn't get any
weirder
sierra became a target
no not that one a target
of lust
okay about the swingers this client came
in to see me every four weeks for a
brazilian we would chit chat and then go
about our day then about the fourth or
fifth time i seen her she tells me that
i've been waxing her
husband's back i was like oh yeah that's
cool i know exactly who that is i didn't
know you knew and blah blah blah then
she's like yeah we both agree that
you're really hot and i was just like oh
thank you i brushed it off no big deal
and she shared with me that they go with
these swinger clubs and they wanted to
take me with them i told her that they
weren't my type and i never seen them
again
when i sat down with sierra it wasn't
long before the topic of vomit
came up have i ever had a client
throw up while waxing them
this comment is triggering because i
hate throw up
i haven't actually had a client throw up
but i've definitely thrown up in between
waxing clients one day i was super
hungover
i was doing this girl's brazilian and i
was just trying to push through the day
she was so sweet and she was talking to
me about like her plans and what she was
doing for the day talking about eating
food
and as soon as she said something about
food i had to excuse myself from the
room i immediately went to the bathroom
and just started like profusely vomiting
and the bathroom was right by my room i
came back in i apologize i was just like
yeah i had a long night i was 21 so
i was a mess if anybody vomited on me i
would simply just have to pass away so
nobody has ever stolen my wax because i
never had it out in the open but i did
have a client steal products out of my
room but like honestly i didn't even
give a i was pretty impressed like i
don't even know how she did it i just
went back into the room and there was no
product and then right after that i made
a grown man cry usually i laugh at men's
tears but this time was different he
came in for a full face wax and i never
did one on a man before as i try to rip
the wax off he immediately burst into
tears and started screaming at the top
of his lungs